>> Dana: A $300 BILLION COVID-19
RELIEF BILL FALLING SHORT IN THE
SENATE.
EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT VOTED
AGAINST THE PLAN.
CHAD PERGRAM IS LIVE ON CAPITOL
HILL.
THE LOSS WAS NOT A SURPRISE?
>> NO.
EVERYBODY KNEW WHICH DIRECTION
THIS WAS GOING TO GO.
THIS WAS NOT A STRAIGHT UP OR
DOWN VOTE ON CORONAVIRUS RELIEF.
THIS WAS AN EFFORT TO MAKE A
FILIBUSTER.
DEMOCRATS WERE FILIBUSTERERING
THIS PIECE OF VOTE.
THE VOTE WAS 52-47.
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT PLEASED WITH
DEMOCRATS BLOCKING THIS.
LET’S START WITH LINDSEY GRAHAM,
REPUBLICAN OF SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> PEOPLE ARE HURTING OUT THERE.
SEEMS TO ME MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES ARE STUCK ON A NUMBER
THAT THEY THINK IS BETTER FOR
THEM TO DENY A DEAL THAT TRUMP
THAN IT IS TO PASS A BILL THAT
WOULD HELP PEOPLE.
THAT’S VERY UNFORTUNATE.
>> EVEN THOUGH THEY NEEDED 60
YAYS FOR THIS, THERE WERE
QUESTIONS AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
MITCH McCONNELL COULD COAX AT
LEAST 51 SENATORS ON HIS SIDE TO
VOTE YES.
McCONNELL WAS COY YESTERDAY THAT
HE MAY NOT HAVE HAD 51 GOP VOTES
THEN BUT HE HAD 52.
RAND PAUL WAS THE ONLY GAP NAY.
REPUBLICANS FAILED TO GET ANY
DEMOCRATS TO CROSS OVER.
>> THIS EMACIATED BILL IS NOT A
SERIOUS ATTEMPT AT LEGISLATION
OR SOLVING THE REAL PROBLEMS IN
OUR COUNTRY.
IT’S A SHAME.
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST CYNICAL
MOVES I’VE SEEN.
>> NOW, THERE’S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT GETTING ANY SORT
OF CORONAVIRUS BILL IS DEAD
UNTIL AFTER THE ELECTION.
I PRESSED HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI ON THAT POINT THIS
MORNING.
SHE SAID NO.
BUT SHE’S ADAMANT THAT SHE
DOESN’T WANT TO ATTACH ANY
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF TO ANY BILL
TO FUND THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE TO DO THAT BEFORE